but you've also done is it uh did you do
a punching game this is hard game she
invented this game what oh
i know we're so close don't touch me
i just wanted to protect my drink she
taught us this game
i didn't i brought it you did bring it
we used to do in the hunger games in
like a normal way because you're bored
you know you spend
minimum 12 hours on set so it's like you
know you see the circle you get punched
and on hunger games it's normal i
brought it to these psychos
and now it's it's truly truly dangerous
did you look
that's normal and that was like that's
terrifying i was like
this is what a vagina looks like
[Applause]
something's going to happen like e.t
with a beard
how do i get unloaded
[Laughter]
oddly you met your wife on the set of dr
who yeah
but she is the daughter of a doctor who
yes which must drive doctor who people
into a frenzy
i mean it is statistically quite
unlikely yeah
um but it oh there we all are look
there's the three of us
yeah oh that's so embarrassing i'm
wearing the seam suit come on
[Applause]
that doesn't make me look very when
swept and celebrity-tastic
i mean it's a very nice one you wouldn't
want me to just wear it once right
now no no you know you know it works you
know it works
well it's like someone's it's our friend
our mutual friend 30 year old friend
eddie
is a massive fan of not that old we
should say
he will be one and he will be sorry but
he's a massive fan of oprah
as we all know and oh you don't but he
is and uh
and like really mega fan and so so so
the so the
the books called that because a story in
the book um is
the title of that so what happened was i
uh was invited to this big
event where oprah was getting honored
getting an award and so i thought i've
got to take eddie as my date
so i did and we got there and he was
just like friends he was like i've got i
want to get a photo with oprah i want to
get a photovoltaic that might not happen
eddie and i'm not going to guarantee it
and i am not going to be because i
thought if that does happen i'd have to
go and say oprah my
friend everyone i'm not going to do that
you know you just have to
it might happen but just you anyway i
said then you know how when
people come up to me in bars and we're
having dinner and they ask for a photo
and how
pissed off you get about that on my
behalf and he went i see a point
i still want a photographer so so
we we're at this thing and there's a big
dinner and it was like crazy
like oprah was at this sort of central
big table like steven spielberg and
jesus and everybody and we were
we were all like at these tables going
around we were sort of like satellites
you know kind of going around oprah and
barbara waters was hosting the thing
and uh and here's ishtak perma he's
and here's jesse norman she's singing
away and then it's just like
full-on and then at one point she goes
and now we're going to have a break
and after the break oprah and we're like
oh my god and so gail oprah's friend
came over to say hello to us
and uh and we were at this kind of
siberia
like table we were like not we were kind
of near the loose and i could see eddie
a bit later
and so but gayle came over so that was
like the nearness of
gail because she's oprah's best friend
and then and then she turned around to
talk to someone and eddie said
ed said her bum was right there and i
did take a picture take a picture i take
a picture of
gail's bum and eddie's head and then and
then he went and he's so
pressured over there and he said take a
picture of oprah far away and me and i
think
so i had this camera i was trying to
zoom it in and it wasn't
my camera it's my husband grant so i was
a little unusual trying to zoom in and i
got her in focus and then suddenly she
stood up i was like oh [__] you oprah
she stood up and started and i was like
ah christ and then i realized
she was coming towards us because she
was going to the loo
and i was like eddie she's coming she's
going to come she's going to come right
by here she's going to totally come this
could
this moment could happen and so i'm
trying to unzoom the thing together
he's all freaking out i can feel his
energy he's like a tingly little thing
and then he and he stands up and he kind
of blocks her path
and i and and i'm trying to fiddle the
thing and i hear him in this little
choir boy
voice going oprah may i have a photo
with you
it would be my dream oh bro
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i snapped a picture and this is one of
the worst pictures i've ever taken i'm
sure you have it for us
to see this is the picture that eddie
dreamed of guessing
i actually think it's perfect because
you know it's absolutely what that
moment was like oprah
oprah is a goddess and she can only be
half present
but eddie it was a bloody mess
but it was 1995 and that was a very
special year for the man sitting beside
you peter capaldi
because that was the year you won an
oscar i won an oscar yes for a little
short film i didn't even know that they
gave oscars for short films
but i'd made this little short film
because i was interested in filmmaking
and the next thing i knew i was being
telephoned and being told that you were
nominated for an oscar
i thought we didn't even have any money
we didn't know how to get over there all
right but we managed to cover to get
enough money to get over there
and we found ourselves at the oscars
with yourself
and lots of other um film stars and
they called my name and i got up on the
stage i looked down and it was a huge
auditorium like this and it just looked
to me as if it was full of
um you know an arnold schwarzenegger
look-alike you know what steve martin
look-alike
tom hanks looked like except that was
the real thing
uh and it was sort of orgasmic i don't
know how it was for you but for me
but i knew it was my last organ
but i do as well it wouldn't last
because obviously when you've just made
a little short film it doesn't have
quite the same
impact uh on your career and also i was
an actor so that just confused
three billion people saw you yeah but as
you know they take you backstage
and they put you on a kind of conveyor
belt and they take you into like a
hangar
which has got the world's press in it
and they put you on a stage and all
those pictures you see if people holding
up their oscar they're sort of taken on
that stage
and then they say would anyone like to
talk to peter capaldi
winner of the short film uh for 1995
one part of aging has affected you
the uh additional grooming that is
required
i like to groom yeah yeah they well are
you
you must be already please all over well
yes you get have you have you gotten a
little idiot no
no really when you're a young young
young man i like to take a tweezer what
do you do i like to take a tweezer and
get the odd
hair out of here oh no i need a flymo
it's just like
well i don't want to get them i don't
want to shave it you know that's an
option
i like to get them out at the root and i
kind of it's like weeding it's like the
the thrill of we the delight of weeding
because you get that thing
and you uh you're clean as a whistle
look at that and
you know you get them it's nice if you
can i got it i got it so there's that
and then there's noes
the the nose issue i how about a bit of
that have you yeah
what's your may i ask it's a trivial and
mundane and not interesting thing but
i ask you because i'm interested in it
it's like you would imagine i do which
is
[Applause]
out you have a you have quite an odd
technique i think no i don't pluck them
out nobody plays them you're not you're
serious about that you don't
use the bug that's not the right idea i
mean i guess
he does it when he's on his bike it's
personal no i had for a second i had
somebody had given me because you can
buy one of those yeah i've heard from
those you do yeah
and you know those things well it's
meant to it's kind of a rolling thing
and you go
and you go like uh i don't trust it and
i'm much much better
with a pair of scissors i take a nice
pair of scissors
well not to get too detailed but here i
take my razor
i take my gillette number two
this part right here i i razor that
very carefully very carefully because
you can get it very close
and then there's something going on here
and all around there and i get a scissor
and there i am and i know just and i
know just what to do
and this happens now about once a week
i'd say
yes i get i get i'm i'm i i guess i'm
living you know i things are happening
well it looks good on you it looks good
i did it recently so it's it's
quite quite good isn't it
yeah and do they tell you what it's just
oh we'd like a meeting or do you know
that you're going to be
the new assistant um well my agent
called me and said
they're looking for a girl to play the
new companion for the new doctor
so um so that's all i knew and i just
did an audition with the casting
director
and um and then i got a recall and i had
to um go into the bbc
sort of studios and say i was
auditioning for something called panic
moon
which is an anagram of companion so they
take it that seriously they take it that
seriously yeah it is
top top top secret i can't use that
anagram anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
but now the reaction to you has been
told me and you were
have you been voted to declare everyone
just said you're the sexiest doctor who
assistant of all time
yeah what's that all about well you were
a stripper in the first episode weren't
you
a pictogram not a stripper a kisser yeah
not a stripper no is it kista grandma
stripper
yes oh
is it true or not that you you kept a
lightsaber
i officially don't own a lightsaber
props guy gave me one no i didn't
because we bought
some lightsabers which i like they're
pretty good aren't they
no oh that one's on already oh hang on
oh no you have to know what you're doing
with these you see
you do though is that the which one
would you like which one looks like
yours
um the one in the middle is i think uh
the the one i use
that's that's alec guinness one oh
they're the shores yeah yeah oh my god
this these are really nice it's amazing
how do you turn them can you bang them
against each other will they break
oh no they won't but you make the sound
effects yourself
do you want to do you want one not at
all come on
there you go there go go go you get a
good sword oh look at that
what that's fantastic but can you make
the noises oh can i is it true that you
did this thing
i'm sure you've been asked this a
thousand times yeah like in rocket they
did this in rocky as well
where they had to you would make the
sound effect yourselves
so they had to go back and like sound
was a nightmare
because it was a bunch of people going
no it wasn't to begin with it was quite
difficult not to make the sound
yeah and also when it goes away because
it makes that nice
noise when it goes down oh yes have you
heard that in rocky the partly like the
in the first film particularly it's just
loads of sound effects of sylvester
still all good
[Laughter]
okay let's look at the light let's put
the lights down let's the lights down
because you have to you have to start
them up
oh okay so off off
how do you do that uh
much deeper on there oh there there it's
all now oh there you go
there you go okay so when you put it on
it has to make this turn nice
[Music]
nice you're so good at it i did it i
spent months doing it
mine keeps going off though when i twirl
it i could oh
break they'll break
how much are they cost 150 quid each
[Applause]
if i are you going to cricket if i throw
you something can you get over do it
over here hang on i'll throw this here
wait who's who you just there you go
actually i should be
can you can you throw a ball chris oh
don't be like that i can't
throw anything don't be done no you go
you go you go you go okay okay here we
go
all right we're good let's baseball
baseball it's dead
okay yay
[Applause]
[Music]